first i want to ask you both what's the
first
piece of like ghostbusters memorabilia
toy or whatever you remember having
uh when you were younger
oh gosh
i don't think i was allowed to have
anything because
no just because there were five kids and
you know we made everything out of
sticks um i'm sure we used some sticks
for proton packs
but before we move on can i just give a
shout out to the canadian crew because
we were up in calgary alberta and like
the canadian crews are where it's at
i've worked there many times and thank
you paul what was your did you have any
ghostbusters toys
i don't think i did
i um
i i you know i was just i was i was too
busy
just eating wonder bread
[Laughter]
walking around and like
going to spencer gifts to see if i could
find a new shoe wallet
but i love ghosts and i i remember i
always loved ghosts and werewolves and
um
you know mummies i was one of those kids
that like like i got a mummy book when i
was six for christmas because i loved i
loved the paranormal and all that stuff
so ghostbusters was a huge part of my
childhood i loved it and it was so funny
and you know
beautiful cast great women annie pot
sigourney weaver all that stuff i
certainly love the film yeah i don't
know if i had any of this stuff but i i
loved the movie and growing up it was a
you know it was a huge movie
it's it's become part of like the dna of
pop culture in north america and you see
not to give anything away and like the
the fan part of me and wants to scream
out all the cool things that happens in
this movie but obviously i can't but you
two get to play out
some of the most coveted like
roles in like from the original
ghostbusters in a way
was there like
how did you approach that were you were
you like giggling to yourself the entire
time the fact that you got to do it
yeah i mean it's it's it's totally
surreal it's like uh as fans of
something to get to walk into the world
of it i mean there's i just don't know i
just don't know many opportunities to do
that you know what's something i don't
even know anything that would work that
way where i get to be a child and enjoy
something and then as an adult i get to
actually
play in the world of that thing i mean i
can't think of anything equivalent can
you
and you can't you can't think about it
too hard because yeah you kind of can't
but it it it's also a little bit
inevitable and when and and and going
back to that question when i was reading
the script
um
you know by
by page two or three i'm just like whoa
oh
oh no way oh no way oh no way and i and
i and i
i just kept having oh no way moments
throughout the entire
script and they kept building and um
and and when i finished it i just
thought oh my god this is such this is
such the this is such the way to make
this movie
yes
now that that clip of um the mini stave
puffed marshmallows
went by everybody loved it did you know
immediately that people were going to go
crazy about this
character about this whole idea of a
miniature yeah they're so cute
right paul they're adorable
i think they yeah they are and they're
cute they're cute even when they're you
know
uh killing each other
i had a feeling
they would only
only that i you know i knew that this
movie has ghostbusters has a really
passionate fan base and there are uh
and
i include myself in that category but
there are so many things
that
i would look around and think oh that's
really cool uh ghostbusters fans were
like that they'll get that in this and
when i was doing that scene where
um you know i'm looking at the stay puft
marshmallow man i yeah i thought oh god
this is this is
this is again this is a very cool way to
kind of
do this it's unique and it's unique to
our story and yet it does have this kind
of this
connective tissue
right like on the scale of cute like
characters that have been at the front
of shows and movies recently with like
baby yoda and all those baby groots like
where would you put
the mini state marshmallow man
oh they're they're tough they're tip top
they're going to make a great christmas
ornament
oh a full full christmas tree of just
marshmallows yeah like sadistic sadistic
baby marshmallows
they're kind of perfect ornament size
it's a really good call gary they um
because you know the other thing that
that
that uh
they have is
longevity you know
stay puft marshmallow man they go
they've been around a while now yeah
yeah your parents knew about the stay
puft marshmallow man
yes yes absolutely well thank you so
much for the time i gotta tell you i i
love this i cried multiple times in the
movie uh so yeah great job
congratulations thanks so much so glad
you enjoyed it